vamos ahora a la 91 en la 91 nos
preguntan en qué porcentaje disminuyó el
ingreso medio por casa en el país de
1970 a 1980 entonces la pregunta es en
qué porcentaje disminuyó el ingreso
medio del país de 1970 de 1970 a 1980
muy bien vamos a ver qué información nos
dan en el inciso 1 nos dicen que en 1970
el ingreso medio por casa en el país fue
dos terceras partes del ingreso medio
por casa del país x osea el ingreso
medio de en 1970 del país fue dos
terceras partes
del ingreso medio del país x ok estoy
aquí no nos va a permitir responder lo
de aquí arriba porque esto solo es una
fotografía en el tiempo solo nos da
información de 1970 vamos a ver qué nos
dice el inciso 2 nos dice en 1980 ok en
1980 el ingreso medio del país
fue igual fue igual a la mitad del
ingreso medio por casa del país x x 80
bueno otra vez este por sí mismo nada
más es una fotografía entonces pues a lo
mejor podemos responder juntando la
información de los dos pero yo digo que
no o sea a simple vista podría parecer
un sistema de ecuaciones con dos
variables y con dos ecuaciones pero no
es así verdad en realidad son cuatro
variables tenemos ya 70 x 70 de 80 y x
80 entonces pues no podemos resolver
incluso podríamos este intentar lo
siguiente verdad como sólo nos piden del
porcentaje pues a lo mejor baste
encontrar de encontrar
este y de 70 entre 80 esto de aquí nos
da que tanto es de 70 con respecto a 80
la proporción pero ni siquiera podemos
encontrar esto verdad porque esto es
según los datos que tenemos dos terceras
partes de x 70 dividido
entre la mitad de x 80 vale y esto es
que esto es igual a pues este 2 v se
convierte en cuatro tercios de x 70 / x
80 pero no tenemos información de esta
proporción así que no podemos conseguir
información de esta proporción vale
entonces la respuesta sería y ni
siquiera juntando ambos incisos podemos
responder vamos al problema 92 en el 92
nos dice que un cierto grupo de
vendedores de autos decidió donar x
dólares a una capilla ok x dólares
dólares a una capilla por cada coche que
vendieran en un periodo de 30 días
entonces por coche por coche
coche vendido vendido en un cierto
periodo de 30 días días ok y lo que nos
preguntan es cuál es la cantidad total
que se esperaba a donar ok esta pregunta
está rara queremos la cantidad cantidad
esperada esperada por donar por donar ok
como podríamos plantear esto pues
tenemos cuánto va a donar o sea x
dólares por cada coche que se venda
entonces si queremos la cantidad
esperada por donar que le vamos a llamar
y tendríamos que multiplicar x por la
cantidad esperada de coches que se
vendan verdad entonces sería x por
digamos donde se es igual al número de
coches coches que se esperaban vender
digamos que se esperaban yo voy a poner
así esperaban vender vender bueno vamos
a ver qué tenemos de información en el
inciso 1 nos dice que se esperaba vender
500 coches ok entonces nos dice que se
hace
es igual a 500 esto no nos dice nada de
de verdad porque todavía nos faltaría
información acerca de x vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 el inciso 2 dicen que
se vendieron 60 carros más de los
esperados y entonces lo que se donó fue
28 mil dólares aunque estos son un poco
interesante entonces si hace
la cantidad de carros vendidos le
sumamos le sumamos 60 y eso lo
multiplicamos por cuánto se dona
entonces nos dicen que eso fue igual a
28.000
a 28 mil ok entonces otra vez esto por
sí mismo no nos va a permitir encontrar
el por qué aquí simplemente sabemos que
se x 60 x es igual a 28 mil 28.000 y por
lo tanto sabemos que ese x o sea y es
igual a 28.000
28.000 menos menos 60 x verdad menos 60
x pero pues si no sabemos x no podemos
saber cuánto es entonces por separado
nos sirven pero si juntamos las dos si
vamos a poder responder la pregunta
porque sabiendo que esto de aquí es 500
entonces podemos sustituir la hace aquí
abajo y tendríamos que 560 x es igual a
28.000
28.000 de modo que x es igual es igual a
28.000 dividido entre 560 y entre 560 y
con el valor de x ya podemos sustituir
aquí arriba verdad tenemos que es igual
a 28.000 dividido entre 560
x 500 y bueno de ahí podríamos encontrar
el valor pero no nos interesa lo único
que nos interesa es saber que combinando
las podemos responder y entonces la
respuesta es sí
muy bien vamos al problema 93 problema
93 muy bien en el problema 93 nos dice
que mientras manejaba en la autopista
raúl o sea más bien está preguntando nos
pregunta si raúl mientras manejaba en la
autopista excedió el límite de velocidad
de 55 millas por hora ok entonces la
pregunta es y raúl la google excedió
dios los o las 55 millas por hora las 55
millas por hora
bueno pues vamos a ver que nos dan de
información en el inciso 1 nos dice que
raúl manejo 100 millas entonces raúl
manejo manejo 100 millas bueno esto
todavía no es suficiente verdad esto
nada más es la distancia que manejo pero
nosotros queremos pues una velocidad o
comparar desde la velocidad de raúl con
una cierta velocidad límite entonces
necesitamos más información que una
simple distancia vamos al inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dice que raúl
manejo por dos horas manejo dos horas
horas el inciso dos por sí mismo nada
más es un tiempo entonces no sirve si
combinamos los dos tenemos que la
velocidad promedio de raúl fue 50 millas
por hora 100 entre 2 es 50 millas por
hora
vale pero ni siquiera sabiendo esto
podemos saber si excedió la velocidad o
no puede ser que sí o puede ser que no
alomejor raúl se puso loco y manejo a 80
millas por hora por un ratito pero luego
ya estuvo manejando a 10 millas por hora
y entonces el promedio si dio 50 o no
sea lo mejor raúl pues nunca excedió
este esta velocidad de aquí siempre
estuvo a 50 millas por hora y también
pudo tener este promedio entonces ni
siquiera sabiendo la información de
estos dos podemos responder la pregunta
de modelo que aquí tenemos que poner
y sale bueno vamos ahora al problema 94
en el problema 94 nos dice que en cierta
escuela la jeferson school 94 la
jefferson de excursión la muy difícil
hay estudiantes que estudian francés
español o ambos y nada más
ok entonces es francés español o ambos o
ambos muy bien nos dicen que 100
estudiantes de estos no estudian francés
entonces 100 no francés
y lo que quieren que determinemos es
cuánto se estudian tanto francés como
español entonces la pregunta es cuántos
estudian francés y español muy bien
vamos a ver qué información tenemos esto
es como un problema de estos de diagrama
entonces quizás sea bueno poner la
información pues en un diagrama verdad
entonces voy a poner aquí un círculo
para los estudiantes que hablan español
y otro para los estudiantes que hablan
francés entonces este de acá es español
que estoy acá es francés
la información que nos dicen es que 100
de ellos no hablan francés o sea este
cachito de acá
este cachito de acá es en 100 sale desde
la información que tenemos y lo que nos
piden es determinar cuántos hablan
francés y español
o sea cuántos están en este caso de acá
muy bien entonces veamos la información
que el que nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dice que hay 60 que no estudian que no
estudian español
60 no no español español
ok español en español
entonces esos 60 están justo en este
caso de acá si aquí tenemos a los 60 que
no estudian español ahora sí sólo
sabemos que esto es 100 y estos 60 pues
no tenemos nadie nada de información de
este cachito de acá así que éste por sí
mismo no es suficiente vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 en el 2 dice que 240 de
los estudiantes 240 estudian español
entonces estudian español me parece que
esto sí es información buena buena para
responder lo que queremos si 240 hablan
español o estudian español más bien
entonces este circuito rojo en total
tiene 240 estudiantes pero ya vimos que
aquí afuera son 100 entonces aquí
adentro los que hablan francés y español
son igual a 240 240 menos 100 menos 100
entonces sería igual a 140 y entonces el
inciso 2 es suficiente para responder y
por lo tanto la respuesta de esta
pregunta sería ve muy bien